[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
ryan hi hi how are you that was very uh
yiddish of you
how are you uh i hope you guys had a
glorious weekend uh our music video uh
came out sunspin
i directed my first music video a little
low budget
music video called summertime neighbor
one of the tracks on the new album
which you can get on itunes and um
amazon on your computer not your phone
just go on your computer and download it
this is a cd see that anyway summertime
neighbor uh the music video came out and
people were digging it
i'm glad it was a fun half a day or
maybe three-fourths of a day work and
it was nice to be out there and you know
just kind of
guiding the ship and enjoying it so that
was uh that was fun
uh what else i watched this uh
documentary on billie holiday
and um it was it was it was a little
heavy
yeah but you know i mean she live she
died at 44 years old
young man and she what a voice and she
just went through a lot in her life and
uh
you know remember i don't know if i'm
quoting her exactly but
she was talking about death and she said
i think we're all trying to put a
hundred days into one
and it was something like that which
really rang true for me
because i think we're trying to do
instead of just living here right now in
the moment
enjoying we're doing a hundred things
we're ahead of ourselves
we're not really enjoying this moment
like i'm not really enjoying my time
with you right now because
me neither i'm kidding what a [ __ ]
drag what a drag man this [ __ ] sucks
but you know it was kind of interesting
it was like she said something like
we're trying to fit a hundred days into
one and it's just like just relax
you know and uh i could be misquoting
her but it was something along those
lines and it just
resonated with me and uh i think that's
the thing we're always thinking ahead so
much we're always thinking about what we
could do
and how we could do and sometimes man i
don't know how many times you hear about
when people on their deathbed they ask
them and just like i wish i just would
have been more present i wish i would
have just
not worked so much i wish i would have
and if you're hearing it from so many
people i mean this isn't just like one
or two people but they've done
studies then why don't we just everybody
just stop
[ __ ] working everybody just stop what
you're doing right now
go hug something uh i don't know
we can't do that now all right no don't
don't hug anybody that's not what i
meant it was uh
well he's a proverbial hug you mean what
you mean what you said hug
something just yeah dug your dog like a
tree hug a door like a door
hug it's
no that's on a person and that could
have coveted on it kovac
it could have coveted deck i don't sorry
for getting crass this early in the
morning i normally don't you know that
so
forgive me um thank you for listening to
the podcast last week was a lot of fun
last week was um
zach levi and uh did very well and
i appreciate everybody listening and he
really opened up more than he usually
does and he opens up a lot normally so
thank you zach levi
please go listen to it if you haven't
the michael cudlitz from walking dead's
great katie cassidy from uh
arrow um hers is really touching and she
talks about her dad david cassidy and
uh so it's important that you guys uh
write a review and if you're enjoying
the podcast it truly helps the podcast
so ryan just give him those uh
uh at inside of you pod on twitter
inside of you podcast on instagram and
facebook yeah so just uh follow us and
on apple podcast or wherever
please write a review and tell me you're
digging the show and that that bumps us
up in the ratings
if that means anything to some people
which it might mean something to my boss
over westwood one they might say oh look
he jumped
a 98. isn't that special isn't that
special
uh if you want to get any cool merch
like uh signed cds of the band go to
sunspin.com
got hats lunch boxes and if you want
anything related to
uh you know smallville lex luthor all
that stuff we've got lex luthor t-shirts
smallville
lunchboxes that's on the inside of you
online store
so you can get that i think there's a
discount code going on right now uh ins
now there's a sunspin code right now the
sunspin code on thesunspin.com
for merch is
sunspin 10
i don't know this [ __ ] i don't even know
try it
try it see if that [ __ ] works i want to
say thanks to uh thanks ryan for
for working so hard and bryce for uh
giving us a good podcast here you guys
are really
you know you put it together and it's
it's it's nice to
i don't know it's nice to be do
something that you're proud of and it's
quality i think we're giving people
quality the sound sound you know it
sounds good it looks good on the youtube
when you edit it uh
equipment's great the equipment's great
we have a nice room here
uh you know you could write in to us at
hello insideapodcast.com
thanks to all my patrons out there who
support the podcast if you want to join
patreon it's wonderful it's a wonderful
family i'll text you right after you
join it's
patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com slash
inside of you
or inside patreon.com inside
view try inside of you or inside anyway
um i think that's it why don't we get
into i guess you know this this guest is
you know him from mtv and jackass and
like all these movies
but he's really started his own little
empire i gotta give it to him i mean
this guy's been through some hell and he
keeps fighting
and keeps coming through and uh you know
he talks he's pretty open about you know
we talked about
i believe unless you cut it ryan about
loving thyself and
you know you like yourself these
questions seem kind of trivial like what
does it really mean
i hate when people ask me that it it's a
legit question i mean ryan if i said do
you like yourself you're
probably going to say hey i'm okay okay
yeah
you love yourself i do okay to see
that's a pretty quick
solid answer i honestly can't
answer those questions as easily but i'm
working on that so
when i ask people sometimes i don't do
it i don't do it to interrogate but
i think sometimes you know
i think that answers deep
down deep inside you
and it's like it it takes i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm saying
it just it takes time to really be
honest with yourself because you could
say yeah i [ __ ] love myself man i
like
i'm awesome i'm [ __ ] great but uh i
think
it stems from childhood i really do
think there's a certain thing where
you know something happens along the way
and i'm not blaming but you know then
you're like
why don't i love myself that's weird i
think i'm a good guy for the most part
but yeah i'm irritable i could be a
little [ __ ]
you know and then you start doubting
yourself and that's what you say you
gotta
really stop that stop being so hard on
yourself so that's what i'm learning
that hey you know you we all [ __ ] up
every day
it doesn't mean you're a bad person you
make mistakes you
[Music]
you know you you you dump your boyfriend
or your girlfriend doesn't mean you're a
bad person
if you cheat on him maybe you're does it
mean you're bad
no it probably means that you did a bad
thing and you're bad in that moment but
does that mean you're bad for the rest
of your life you're terrible i'm not
insinuating that i i'm cheating i or i
have a girlfriend to cheat on
for that matter i'm just saying in
general let's get into
stevo it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael
[Music]
rosenbaum
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
what's up dude i'm just kicking it man
what a great bed are you in an rv man
i sure am this is my traveling
podcast studio tattoo shop
movie trailer uh
surf mobile you have a tattoo shop
in your trailer we had
it's it's it's a class b motorhome
built on a dodge ram chassis
it's a a little bit smaller than your
average tattoo shop but we get it done
do you know how to tattoo people or you
have someone who tattoos
no no i do man i'm actually uh
an apprentice at this time um
it seems that tattoos from stevo are in
rather high demand
are they are they quality they are
surprisingly good
for a tattoo from stevo i've got a
tattoo portfolio
that uh that i'm just
so uh serious about man you know
i i really put effort into it and it
came about
uh i never thought about it you know
like
the first tattoo i ever did was i think
uh
2006 and and someone just uh
produced a tattoo machine while i was on
stage performing in front of a crowd
i wanted to be quick about it i never
wiped away the ink i was just tattooing
in this big mess of
black ink and then i was tattooing my
name
when i finished and wiped away the ink i
had misspelled my own name
it said stevo and uh
and it was just an awful experience
overall and um
and over the years you know when
presented with a tattoo machine i'd be
like yeah sure
but then a year and a half ago i decided
what if i really tried what if i took on
you know somewhat ambitious designs and
did my absolute best
and i was surprised by the results so
now uh
i got a whole apprenticeship um
um i i believe i've just sold a
television show called stevo's bad
news tattoos you believe you sold the
show you're not sure yet
wow like we've sold the uh uh
it's not a pilot i think they don't make
pilots anymore
as much um because it because
when the pilots shot they can't they
can't really
air it because it sticks out like a sore
thumb as not part of the series
right so they sort of scale it back and
i understand that we've been granted 75
to make a proper presentation of what
the show would look like
right now now see i i i think about
things like art
and that's one thing i run from like i i
i'm not a good artist i can barely make
a 3d
l or you know how you do you know how
you make it look 3d
like i i couldn't even imagine that so
were you like
did you were you always drawing and
drawing cool [ __ ] and designs
i think it's a misconception that
tattooing
is is a function of drawing it's really
much more a function of tracing
you know you'll trace on the carbon
paper for what's called the stencil and
then
you'll trace over that with the needle i
mean sure when you get into shading and
stuff there's
there's a level of uh art to it but
you don't have to actually draw the uh
the thing you trace it but i'm
colorblind too
good so
yeah i mean maybe it's not for you and
it's a lot of work man
there's no question about it but um
there's a level of satisfaction that
comes with with being surprised by
uh the fact that you did a better job
than you thought you could
well that's what got me well kudos you
know i look at your
life and all this [ __ ] everybody knows
you and your world famous you got
two you know five million people on
youtube watching your channel and you do
these kind of
sit down talk about your life and
moments and
intercut videos and it's really cool i
just watched the surfing one about how
you had his wrong name and everybody was
[ __ ] up the dude's name
that surfed this giant wave but you you
yeah you posted it and uh unfortunately
you were called the [ __ ] 22 million
people
i guess tweeted the wrong person you you
[ __ ] his name up so they gave it well
right yeah i i saw a clip and the buddy
of mine had posted
it was this guy surfing like an 80-foot
wave
there was uh you know they were saying
it was the biggest wave ever written and
i thought right on you know and i posted
it too
uh giving credit to what turned out to
be the wrong surfer
and uh you know a bunch of people had
posted this clip
crediting the wrong surfer but i was the
guy
who's whose post got 22 million views
jesus sorry so that was the headline
stevo posts
big waves sir wrong server
guy uh what's your dog's name there
this is wendy wendy yeah i found her in
the street support you really look like
a hoe wendy
yeah your legs propped up there get your
act together
yeah um this dog is a bit of a celebrity
in her own right i found her
in the streets of peru and um
this is bittersweet but the video that i
made
and posted of finding this dog
in the streets of peru is the most
viewed piece of content that i've ever
posted online
it got over 100 million views the video
of me finding this dog and uh
as wonderful as as it is it's
heartwarming and
and this dog is my companion but for
[ __ ] sake the lengths i've gone to to
try to get attention and
and and it said the finding that dog
video that was ahead
unfortunately it was the wrong dog
[Laughter]
yeah it's uh it stings that that was the
most attention i ever got but what can
you do i think that's kind of cool
think about it man it's like something
it's like affectionate it's
empathetic it's like it's it's like what
people really like so it's like a side
of you maybe that they weren't used to
are accustomed to sure
i'll give you that i'll give you that so
yeah definitely
uh i mean i've been through you know
walked through entire days with this dog
and and
every single person that uh
that stopped for a photo knew her by
name it was because it's crazy man
that's all you know i look at all this
[ __ ] man and
you know i look at your life and i'm
like here's a guy your dad was corporate
right he was kind of a corporate guy
and you you go you go to clown school
you went to barnum bailey
for like circus school which i mean were
you doing [ __ ] at a young age
your dad's in a suit and tie and you're
like jumping off cliffs and
you know i mean a little bit sure i mean
uh
i i heard a story about uh
me as a toddler you know not even
walking i don't think
and they said there was like climbing
out of a window on some like
15-story you know
apartment or something um
yeah i was definitely acting like an
[ __ ]
from a very early age and and
my over-developed need for attention
was uh prominent
you know out of the gate so i've always
been an attention [ __ ]
and um you know and at whatever age
there was always just something
that uh that i was acting out with did
you feel like it was uh because you know
with me i i can relate
i always wanted to make my father laugh
i always wanted him to like accept me i
always wanted
and my dad was very corporate work you
know six to five or six every night and
you know
i think i was sort of like my mom in a
way where i was kind of all over the
place
the short attention span didn't know
what the hell i was doing wasn't good in
school
started you know acting and things like
that and just
i think he just kind of looked at me
like ah [ __ ] this son i guess the next
sun's gonna be better and
you know my brother brother was smarter
and they got along better in fact my mom
once was
she i remember saying oh mark to my dad
i know eric's your favorite we all know
eric's your favorite
in front of me and i'm like jesus i mean
i knew it but to hear my mother say it
so what i'm saying is i always was like
i couldn't it wasn't enough
and i felt like i was always trying to
get attention from other people from
whatever to
because i didn't get that attention with
my dad do you think that there was part
of that
is eric an older brother eric is my
younger brother he's he's the smarter
one yeah he's uh he's like six years
younger
so i think that to me is an indication
that neither of your parents are
alcoholic
is that right that's actually you know
my mom was sort of a pill popper a
little bit my dad really never drank but
he was extremely strict you know even
though he did a bunch of [ __ ] which i
didn't know
i mean if you like you would have been
in prison like
my dad if it was you because he i i
remember i got my ear pierced by the
next door neighbor and i looked at him
with my opposite ear and i go hey
what would you think i've ever got my
ear pierced he goes you'd go to a
halfway house is what you do
i go oh see well i'm going to be at
nate's next door for the next week till
this heals
you know what i mean so like so was your
father like that was he strict was he
did you feel like he needed to act out
or well yeah i mean
my whole family dynamic is is uh it
really explains everything
um i'd say you know take it
uh you know sort of one piece at a time
yes my dad was strict and he was a
corporate executive but his job
um involved a great deal of travel so he
was
almost not there more than he was there
and so it was a very inconsistent like
if dad was around he would try to kind
of uh compensate for the time he was
gone by being more of a disciplinarian
i i think you know and so it was just
like
dad's not here i can do whatever dad's
here oh you know it's
sort of an inconsistent thing and um as
far as
the family dynamic goes my dad
uh was actually sort of the black sheep
of his family
for choosing a career in business
he came from just a long
line of academics scholars
theologians clergymen zoologists
you know like he was uh it was very
very like incredibly academic
and and lower earnings uh lineage that
my dad came from
you know he grew up with with
very little money but just a lot of
prestige you know all this uh
scholastic kind of kind of thing and
then and uh you know
his dad was a published author and a
zoologist and
had a decorated uh you know army
colonel um all this very very respected
family and then dad's gonna go into
business and that was like all right
well that's not what i would have chosen
for you
son you know um and then on my mom's
side of the family
it's all alcoholism
you know gambling suicide like addiction
like
just really really dark uh you know
addiction stuff
and um the way that that works
i i have an older sister i'm the second
of two children
and um it's sort of a cookie-cutter kind
of deal
that
parent that the first child
will will really over achieve you know
it's like wow i'm
not being noticed you know like i've got
like my parents have other stuff going
on they're not paying attention to me
to try to get noticed i'm gonna over
achieve i'm gonna get straight a's
look at me i'm perfect you know is that
enough for you and uh
and i think that that's that's a pretty
regular
sort of stereotype that really applies
to my situation
where i have this overachieving older
sister and then i come into the picture
you know there's not a lot of intention
being doled out by either parents
because dad's gone and mom's drunk
and my sister is this perfect straight a
character
doing everything right and you know the
second child comes along and looks at
the efforts of the older child and says
wow there is no [ __ ] way i can
compete with that
you know like i'm not even going to try
to compete with the straight a's and
and do everything so i'm just going to
try to get through
like you know based on uh you know you
know just
being a class clown kind of like go for
laughs you know like that
you know and uh not even try to to
achieve anything
um but at the end of the day what my
dad's family brings to the table is this
like intense drive for whatever it's for
and so like i'm a hybrid
of my dad's who's this my dad's side's
sort of tenacity and and perseverance
coupled with my mom's sides
uh what do you call it uh
deviance you know deviance and and uh
dysfunction and so i'm like just this
hyper
perseverant [ __ ] you know like
deviant
with uh you know a really over developed
need for attention and i think that when
you look at it that way it makes sense
how it turned out the way i did
yeah i read something where it was like
it was years later because you know
you know your mom was sick she had an
aneurysm or something and and you're
yeah your dad was you guys were talking
outside and this was like two thousand
three and he and he was it was that was
actually in 1998 my mom died in 2003
um and and she died after
having survived a brain aneurysm
five years prior and it was just sort of
like one of these things where
you know i understood that she like
cooked some three-course
meal you know like with normal normal
and then like the next morning
i kind of got up and and and whatever
happened like she had just had a blood
vessel and her brain just
popped there was no way to see it coming
or anything and
uh it was just a super you know get her
to the hot you know
and most people don't survive these uh
subarachnoid brain hemorrhages um
you know and mom did survive it but
what was left really uh
physically and mentally disabled and um
and whatever
in the you know she had brain surgery
all this and and the family
came from adult dad i think had flew
over from england and and
my sister and i were in albuquerque new
mexico we all met in florida
and it was just this kind of crisis
management situation
and um and we left at the hospital just
for a meal
and it was it was uh at this this
restaurant
and you know there's crazy circumstances
where moms
you know got this brain thing
and uh and dad chose that time to say
hey son i feel i've done a disservice to
you
um by not supporting you in this career
path that
you've clearly committed yourself to and
he said you know
my dad i didn't choose what my dad
wanted he had a similar conversation
with him you know
and son you didn't yeah
you're not doing what i would have
chosen for you but given that you're
committed to it
i i you know i just want you to be the
best at it you know what i pledged to
support you
and it put a lot of wind in my sails did
you were you emotional
um i mean was it was a heavy
heavy uh situation i mean that was like
the least of what was going on at the
time yeah
it meant a lot you know um it was almost
like all right you know i
almost didn't think that that would
really change a whole lot
i was like okay well you know i'm kind
of a loser at that point i had not
made any money i had not i
really accomplished anything i've i'd
had uh you know
photos and a couple of skateboard
magazines and the photos were not of me
skateboarding
you know like i just did not have my act
together and uh
so it's a big credit to my dad that he
you know didn't jump on the bandwagon
after i had some success
you know like i i really love to say
that i don't feel
uh having a great relationship with my
father is because i'm successful
but rather i think that you know i've
been able to achieve
some success because i have a great
relationship with my father and that's a
really just a really major distinction
that
that that does make me feel emotional
you know my dad's support has been a big
deal
inside of you is brought to you by
better help
this is uh these guys are one of my
favorites we talk about this
obviously if you're listening to the
podcast right now a lot of guests we
talk about adversity we talk about
anxiety
getting through life and we all have a
tough time sometimes
ryan i know you have a tough time i know
i have a tough time
and it's important to talk about it you
know a lot of people ask me
you know what is therapy and really
therapy is whatever you want it to be
therapy could be dealing with um
depression
and talking about your depression and
why you're sad a lot of the times or
if you have anger issues or you want to
just get something off your mind it
could really be
anything just talking to someone
confiding in someone
that you can trust i mean these are
therapists everything you say or tell
them is confidential
so um i think that's really important
and we all need someone to talk to
besides just our buddy who has no real
insight and no education into what we
really need
um it's time to stop being ashamed of
normal human struggles
start feeling better because you deserve
to be happy
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy i could tell you that because
especially in hollywood therapy is
skyrocketed i mean one hour with someone
is is just
astronomical and um it's incredibly
affordable at better help
and you could have a therapist in under
48 hours join the millions
of people who are seeing what therapy is
really about it may or may not be for
you but it's worth looking into
because you are the greatest asset this
podcast is sponsored by better help and
inside of you listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp.com
inside inside of you is brought to you
by true underdog
podcast raised in a trailer park with no
clear path to success kicked out of high
school multiple times faced with
becoming a father in his teens
jason waller is the definition of a true
underdog
after hearing the words no or you can't
too many times
he unleashed the power within to start
three successful companies with his most
recent venture power home solar
skyrocketing on a path to becoming a
billion
dollar enterprise join us as waller
a four-time entrepreneur of the year
winner shares motivational tips and
inspiring stories
and business building lessons from the
ground up he shares his life experiences
and that of his high profile to help
others better themselves
as waller will tell you there's no
elevator to success
that climb only happens one step at a
time
let every true underdog podcast be that
step that elevates you
scared money won't make money
learn about failure learn about
entrepreneurship
learn about never quitting or making
excuses
it's real it's raw it's motivational
check out true underdog podcast at
trueunderdog.com or anywhere you get
your podcasts
that's profound man because yeah i mean
like i i've never really heard that i
think
there's certain people are built a
certain way like you're built a certain
way you're an entertainer you like to do
crazy things and you just go with your
gut and you you know you explore and
and then there's some people who are
like this is what i know and they don't
understand that
other side that side of you or whatever
and
to appreciate it to respect it to be
able to look at someone and go hey he's
not like me
you know i don't think i've had that
like you know i think my dad does the
best he can with
with me with the way he feels like it's
just like hey the nurses need some
pictures
at the hospital for your sister you know
i'm like okay i'll sign them up
it's not hey i just want you to know
if you if you suck if you fail i love
you i
that's that doesn't exist that's never
existed in my life i've never heard it
right so i was kind of curious and so
and i i didn't know that like he
approached you like this before you had
the success so again when you said
that that's that's a profound what did
that do for you did that kind of open it
i'm so excited to answer the question um
it put [ __ ] wind in my sails man like
that that um
the year was 1998
and i think that uh you know at the time
there were
at the time the video camera was really
not
like a household item you know not in
like every household didn't have a video
camera let alone
everybody having a video camera in their
pocket you know there was
about enough home video cameras to
sustain
uh america's funniest home videos
and at that time i think that the uh
you know at that time there was another
show that had come up
called real tv and uh real tv was
you know america's funniest home videos
was
family friendly and kind of really funny
and like you know
this is light and fun like real tv was
more like
gnarly stuff caught on tape you know
like it was
a little bit darker a little bit you
know and um
it was after that conversation with my
dad that i saw
a commercial on tv for real tv
and and it was this pitch you know it
says hey if you hit
um i saw this commercial and it said if
you have
a video that you think we should see
then
send it on into real tv and i was like
oh well [ __ ] you know like i had tons of
videos
so i had all these videos i sent them in
you know and it was like i
called the numbers i said i um i don't
have footage that you might want to see
i have footage that you need badly
you know i'm just going to put it like
that like i'm sitting on some gold
and um and so they got back to me and
they gave me the information to mail it
in because
you know watching footage on the
internet wasn't even a thing
i i sent in the footage they got back to
me they said we really like the clip of
you
uh on top of the three-story building
setting yourself on fire and doing the
fire breathing
flip off the roof into the pool and i
was like
is that all out of everything i [ __ ]
sent you that's all
that you guys want they were like yeah
and we just want that clip we want you
jumping without the fire then we want to
show you jumping with the fire
and they said we want to give you 500
for exclusive rights to
these clips and i was like well what
does that mean i've never heard of such
a thing and they were like well then
that means that we own
and and you know we own it exclusively
only on owners of it
so i'm like so i came and like show
people like basically no
you know i'm like [ __ ] you know i want
to be on tv
you know i've never been on tv but like
i don't want to give away my rights
so in a panic i called it my dad like
dad they had to have an exclusive you
know
my dad just trademarked that he said he
said son
or whatever he said look steve like calm
down
take a breath okay this is really simple
he says you've got to just
figure out at which point it's a deal
breaker for you
you draw a line in the sand and you just
stick to it
since it sounds to me like it's a deal
breaker this exclusivity clause
so why don't you call them back and say
i'm not okay with uh giving away
exclusive rights you can have
non-exclusive rights and you gotta give
me a thousand dollars for that
and uh and that's what i did and that's
and they were they had no problem with
it
okay cool not exclusive if you get a
thousand bucks and uh and that was like
my first
um my first deal you know first step in
negotiation
this is my first and it's more
negotiating than i ever did
for jackass guys
given that i had this you know high
power business
father in my corner you know it seems to
follow that i
could should have done much better with
all the jackass deals over the years
but uh but i i suppose i'm also glad
that i didn't
um die too hard
didn't die and didn't push too hard to
where like it would have soured the
relationship you know because everything
worked out well in the end
right so from there it's sort of like
you know that video you were when you
saw it on tv we were like oh [ __ ] was it
just like that feeling of like look at
this
it was much more anti-climactic because
i thought that being on tv was gonna
really change something or other you
know like and it was just
that [ __ ] thing came and went not one
person ever mentioned that they saw it
it was you know there's a very different
experience
having that one clip come out on real tv
compared to when uh when i had my first
like real bit on jackass which was the
the
swallowing the goldfish and barfing it
up into a fishbowl
um that one i i had one thing on the
first episode of jackass but you could
barely recognize me and it wasn't like a
really notable bit
it was the second episode of jackass
where i had the goldfish trick
and um i did dude
there was an audience for jackass right
away and and and like
the next day like like 24 hours
like within 24 hours of that goldfish
bit
playing for the first time i noticed
that my life was different
you know like like i could like i heard
about it
like all over the place and um it was it
and it was crazy
and um i think that uh
when it was maybe maybe one week after
that
i got a call from the executive producer
guy and he said uh
you know he said uh all right here's the
deal the show's a hit you know
now like we had done eight episodes for
the first season
you know for the entire first season i
was paid
less than 1500 bucks after taxes as i
recall
each episode no i got paid per bit i
didn't get paid
per episode i got paid per bit it was
500 bucks for a bit
if it was uh like dangerous and and
risky
and if it was just like a little gag or
you know a prank
that wasn't like uh high impact
then it was 200 bucks so it's like a
stunt man literally like a stuntman the
more dangerous it is the more money you
make but they're not paying you that
much money
yeah right uh-huh like a medical study
when i had the government test drugs on
me
the more dangerous study the more money
you get right right right
uh but yes so i got paid um per bit and
all of the bits put together
you know it was like 1500 bucks uh about
after taxes and um
and and and so i got this call like
three episodes in
and they said all right we like the
show's a hit it's the highest ratings
that mtv's ever had for
like a half hour format kind of a thing
and so we know we got to pay you
and mtv's ordering 16 episodes you know
like there's eight episodes per season
they're ordering seasons two and three
and one go 16 episodes
and we know we gotta pay you so we're
going to give you 2
000 bucks per episode and i and i
remember thinking uh
16 times 2 000
that's thirty two thousand dollars i'm
[ __ ]
rich like
i was just like you know like
never even you know i don't know man
like i think that like as i grew up and
the house got bigger because dad was
increasingly successful you know like
i was really self-conscious about um my
privileged upbringing you know like the
big house i was embarrassed to have kids
from school like come over and see that
i lived in this big
house you know like um i was i was kind
of ashamed of my parents wealth
and um you know and and as a result i
was just never
i never really found myself uh you know
motivated by wealth like no you know and
i just didn't i just
needed very little to get by and so he
had 32 000 bucks like holy [ __ ] man
i'm rich and you didn't negotiate you
didn't negotiate that way i
i didn't negotiate at all no not not
whatsoever and
um i remember we started filming
um i i got paid half
uh towards the beginning
and um 32 000 after taxes came to like
20 000
and i got half of that so i received a
check for 10
000 and um when i found out that i was
going to receive a check for ten
thousand dollars i called up the
director jeff tremaine and i said yo
dude i'm about to get a check for ten
thousand dollars and that [ __ ]
isn't even gonna be cleared i'm gonna
put it in the bank and before it even
clears into the account
i am going to be [ __ ] in my car
driving
out to california i was in florida at
the time and i'm going to drive
[ __ ] you know i'm going to put it i'm
like driving out delhi i'm moving out to
l.a to [ __ ] ride this wave
and uh and jeff tremaine said that i
said you're not going anywhere until you
send me a list of ideas
to film in every state between florida
and california and if the list is on
point then i'll fly out a production
team to follow you across country and
get all this footage on the road
so that's what we did and it put me way
ahead of uh
of the game for a shooting for for those
you know
for the third season i suppose um and
yeah that was the deal man i moved out
there and i got out to california and
everyone was like dude
you know you better strike while the
iron's hot man you know you're
you're [ __ ] the show's gonna be
canceled you're gonna it's kind of
this moment's gonna pass and i found
that frustrating because i was just
trying to like
be in the moment yeah and then and
that's like kind of
everybody was a little bit right you
know i mean they are right like
up to that point i viewed all of my
video footage
like in sort of like a dark like
religious kind of a way
that like [ __ ] we're all going to be
dead
but i want to live forever and when i
videotape something that [ __ ] video
can play after i'm dead so i won't be
dead at all like i'm going to [ __ ]
live forever and i had this like
this super like just like
sacred view of like the immortality
of video footage you know footage is
forever like oh
you know right there's this huge
importance to what i was doing
but then when i got out to california
and everyone's like oh it's going to be
you know
just strike while they're on top like it
really dawned on me
the footage is not [ __ ] forever you
know that that when
when you're uh doing when you're
actually in the game
the footage has an expiry date you know
like
the footage comes out and then it just
spoils
you know like once you're down once it's
it's rotten and then like nowadays
that's gone like now what are you gonna
do you know and then and life turns into
this uh
this really [ __ ] frantic
desperate pathetic like you know chasing
the spotlight around to try to always
have like
and and and the like like what like
where what's next you know like what do
you got next it's just this scary
daunting question like [ __ ] you you have
to have something next or you're
you know you're only as good as what
you're doing right [ __ ] now
and i hate that i've always hated that
when people like well so what are you up
to
um i'm right here with you right now
that's what i'm up to right
that's what what is this oh i got this
and and then you feel worse when you
start talking to people go
oh i'm doing this and i'm writing this
and i'm doing shut the [ __ ] up
you know i don't need to sit here and
talk about it you feel stupid because
you almost feel like you're defending
not doing anything right right sure
and i found it scary i found it
frustrating and the idea of being in the
limelight you know being in the
spotlight is
it's inherently [ __ ] dark and
and depressing because you know it's
it's a temporary situation you know to
try to
keep that going it's like a lot of
pressure and it's a lot
but um whether i liked it or not whether
i
you know whether it was [ __ ] up
there's nothing healthy about a life
as in you know an entertainer in show
business there's nothing [ __ ] healthy
about fame or celebrity
but at the same time nobody's trading it
in and um
you know from when i from when i got out
to california i just felt like oh [ __ ]
you [ __ ] everybody like you want us
you're telling me to strike when the
iron's hot [ __ ] you like i'll make the
[ __ ] iron hot dude
[ __ ] you can strike you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know like
[ __ ] you know and it just motivated
me and um
from that from the very beginning and
even when i was like wildly out of
control on drugs like i just like
i just hit the hustle button you know
like i i
i know that when when when jackass first
got ordered like i said i had all this
video footage all this [ __ ] that i sent
into real tv and stuff
and when jeff tremaine first told me
that the pilot got ordered to series
he said the first thing you do is uh
pack up all the video footage you got i
know you got a lot and send it to us so
we can license it and just put some of
it straight onto the show
and i was like [ __ ] right on and um
when i sent it in he told me uh
i just i i called back and i'm like dude
so what are you guys gonna use
and he was like sadly not one clip you
sent us
uh is allowed on tv
like i mean to be fair in some cases it
was just
shitty [ __ ] dubbed back and forth the
quality was low
in some cases it was just filmed bad but
for the most part
my thing was like my specialty was
jumping off roofs
you know and uh my my motto was that
whatever you're doing it's cooler if
you're on fire
[Laughter]
and uh two of the rules that we had
like they kind of you know we had uh
rules that we had to kind of uh
follow and that was that if we were
gonna jump off of something off of
jackass
it couldn't be over a certain height
because uh they were really worried
about little kids
copying it and mtv had like all kinds of
problems with fire
where like uh they had one lawsuit
where uh a kid in a trailer park
like burned down the trailer killed his
sister
and they were like why did you do that
and he says beat his
fire fire you know like and then mtv was
found liable
so and then they had another fire and
then another lawsuit going to
but empty just didn't [ __ ] with fire you
know
i hear you are a fire guy yeah i'm the
fire i'm 100 the fire guy man and like
if i'm not if i'm not jumping off
something
that's way too high for mtv i'm
probably doing that i'm probably on fire
while i'm doing that
and if it's not either of those things
then it's something like even more
[ __ ] up
you know because i was uh i i had a real
mad for dark [ __ ]
and um and the point being i tell that
because
out of the gate the the first impression
i had the show and i think this was
before it even was
called jackass when they had ordered it
i think it was like working titles
you know um i thought [ __ ] man
like this is kind of like weird like
it's gonna be cool if we get a tv show
but how
how watered down is it gonna be you know
like what kind of a [ __ ] pussy-ass
show is this gonna be
i thought oh well you know they're
telling me
that i can make uh two hot tv videos
because in that
time during that whole era you know late
night tv was littered with girls gone
wild you know like
kind of these like not a lot on tv
videos and if you call
right now right throw in a bonus video
right so i i knew that i was going to be
making
too hot for tv dvds and i got to work
with that like
really pretty quickly and you know it
was like i teamed up with some people
who
didn't think it was important to pay me
[Music]
seems like you've done that a lot
yeah for sure i mean let me ask you yeah
do you do you feel like
now after you know you got control of
the drinking you've been sober what 10
years
12 years 12 years uh and you're engaged
you still engaged her
i am i'm still engaged all right so look
so you survived somehow you did all
these things and here you
are we're we're in our 40s you're
probably in your 40s right 46.
all right you're younger than i am but
now you're sitting in your trailer and
you're doing tattoos and you're going on
the road
you got this youtube channel are you
able like a few minutes ago you were
talking about
you just want to be in the moment and
like they're saying you got to do this
you got to do this and it kind of [ __ ]
up that moment when you start to feel
like things all
all the stress builds up and all you
have to do do you feel now sitting here
do you feel
like you're enjoying the moment now do
you feel like you're getting a grasp on
him
it's such a gnarly question you know and
i
i would uh you know compare that
question to
it's i feel i find it so uncomfortable
if somebody says
uh i used to find it uncomfortable to be
asked
are you happy yeah i didn't say happy
seems
so like such a simple question are you
happy
and and over the years i feel like
that being asked if i'm happy made me
terribly uncomfortable
because my honest answer my
gut instinctual my instinctual answers
no i'm not [ __ ] happy
yeah you know and and uh i just know
that i'm not
[ __ ] happy i know that i don't enjoy
the moment and
yeah i do enjoy some moments but overall
i have this like this uh overwhelming
sense of impending doom
you know and maybe it's uh that same
impending doom about oh you strike while
the iron's hot you're going to be a
hazard maybe that's just like
[ __ ] scarred onto my brain but when i
think about it
and i finally come to terms with that
question and i've come to terms with my
honest answer being no i'm not happy
and i've come to terms with that because
i finally decided you know
what the [ __ ] does being happy get you
you know what does being happy
like oh i'm happy i'm content okay so
i'm just gonna
chill you know like no like
i think that that uh i have a sense of
impending doom
some feeling that everything is not
[ __ ] okay
that it's not gonna be [ __ ] okay and
i better
frantically hustle to try to
work to make things okay and as
such i'm not comfortable i'm not happy
but that's where my hustle comes from
you know and and and i
like rather than be lazy
and content i would rather be super
uncomfortable
and [ __ ] hustling like a maniac to
get [ __ ] done you know
yeah so like it's a point of pride for
me that i'm not
happy but i'm not content um that i
can't enjoy the moment
because it's just like ah i've gotta
gotta make [ __ ] happen i gotta admit and
and
and so then i i feel like there's
another component to the question is
that
you know beyond am i enjoying the moment
am i able to
to be happy but like have i gotten
you know having done like that like
pretty bad business over the years i was
never motivated by money i'm just an
attention [ __ ]
you know i didn't do very well
business-wise
every attempt at investing money has
just completely gone sideways on me
and uh you know but but at this point
where i'm at now
you know and and as a result of being
sober able to focus myself and not waste
time
making bad decisions but really just
kind of apply myself uh
deliberately in in productive ways like
i
i'm finally kind of getting better at
the business
side of things you know um like uh i've
put together
like with with uh my attention whoring
i've been able to
put together a substantial following
on social media and you know i really
care i care so much about
the quality of the content that i put
out and i think that that
like has built a level of good will with
my audience you know they know that if i
post something that like they can
click play and that it's generally they
can count on it being a good video
that kind of thing and with that
following it doesn't mean that you're
doing well you know like to have a big
social media following it is like
sort of like you know having a
storefront with lots of traffic coming
through but that doesn't really
accomplish much if there's nothing on
the shelves that you have for sale
you know like it's it's like the social
media is an
engine and you need that it that that
engine's not attached to anything
then then nothing's really happening
inside of you is brought to you by geico
you gotta love geico man geico geico
easy geico bundling
all in one i mean you're talking about a
guy who just can't
doesn't get his crap together geico
helps me get my crap together i don't
have to deal with other insurance
policies
an audible policy a homeowner's but i
just do it all with geico it's geico
easy
i i have a home i have monthly bills and
i have auto in ryan you live in an
apartment
and you and you have auto bills dude i
got a lot of bills is that what you call
them auto bills auto bills
car bills car bills car bills you have
car balls
and you have uh marbles you have um rent
guest balls
and uh i mean the last thing you want to
do with all the editing you have to do
ryan is
paid checks to different people why
wouldn't you want to just do it it's a
bundling policy it's a geico easy the
geico makes it easy
to bundle all these things bundle your
homeowners or renters insurance along
with your auto policy it's a good
thing it's easy and you already have so
much to do around your home we all have
too much to do
just go to geico folks go to geico.com
you get a quote you see how much you
could save
it's geico easy visit geico.com today
that's geico.com even a rosenbaum
can do it i see a lot of parallels with
unite it's weird it's just like you know
because that's the same feeling like i
always felt really bad if somebody asked
me that [ __ ] question
and i didn't say you're happy i just
felt like are you in a better place and
i think what i
you know people say are you happy and i
go and i felt [ __ ] horrible that i
couldn't immediately just say yes
because innately it was no right and i
was like but
but look around you and i'm grateful and
all these things i'm like what's
[ __ ] wrong with you with therapy and
this and that
like what why can't you be uh you know
but then
you know what makes me happy and i think
maybe you could
maybe you could accept this is that the
fact that we're talking about it
the fact that we've worked on ourselves
the fact that we've come from a certain
place and that we're trying
to to to to be better and better as
whatever as a person i feel like you're
doing that
to be better as a person to be better as
a human being to be better as a a friend
whatever it is those things and it
sounds so corny
but if you look at yourself kind of out
of control on drugs and lighting
yourself on fire and doing all this [ __ ]
and now you're petting a dog and you're
you know
you're doing these videos and you're
sober and you're doing maybe you could
at least
in retrospect go well
i'm happier i'm actually aware aware
aware aware of what i'm what i'm saying
right
and i i don't want to create the
impression that like i'm miserable and
that i hate my life because
it's not that it's it's not that and i'm
profoundly grateful
for for the progress that i've made
like intellectually i can absolutely
grasp
like uh you know how
uh how pleased i am with the way things
are going
you know um and uh
you know it's it's a philosophy of
buddhism
that all suffering comes from
craving and that and
and that whether things are good or
insane
this is like a buddhist thing but i kind
of really latched on to
um if if we're in pain we crave for that
pain to end
it's just common sense you know but if
we're having some pleasurable
sensation we
every bit as much grave we crave for
that pleasurable sensation to intensify
to last longer you know like
no matter what [ __ ] situation we're
in as human beings
we crave for you know
more good and like i and so that's why
people who have
millions and millions of dollars they
crave more you know like there's just no
[ __ ] situation you can put the human
being in
you know where it's enough
and you don't crave something with
something more and that's why
like the philosophy of buddhism is that
uh
you know it's your happiness you just
have to be happy on with what is not
with how you want it to be
you know like that's like being in the
present like accepting
this how [ __ ] is and and i i don't even
try that i was i was telling my buddy i
was saying
yesterday to my friend tom i was like i
just i'm always anxious he's like what
do you mean
he's like yeah and i go but it makes you
spend everything
he's like like what i go like everything
like i gotta go down and get the mail
i'm anxious
i gotta take a [ __ ] now i wanted to do
something but i have to [ __ ] i'm anxious
yeah a hundred percent do you take any
medication
yeah i i'm trying something right now
that kind of helps with anxiety that uh
you know in in the beginning stages so i
i haven't really felt any effect
are you on something yeah i got a
psychiatrist
and i take zoloft and and i absolutely
it does it's not anything that gives you
a buzz like like
it's never in any circumstance has been
considered a substance of abuse
i just find that if uh if if i'm
not taking zoloft like a a relatively
minor disturbance something that bothers
me
like you know something that bothers me
a little bit can
very easily send me to suicidal ideation
you know right yeah you know i've never
been
by proactive on any level you know about
killing myself but what i have done
at you know and particularly when not
taking zola
is just squander a lot of valuable time
with like
some crazy like fantasies about how like
you know like about how
like i could make it so nobody would
ever discover the body and that it would
be this mystery what happened to him
yeah like all those crazy this crazy
dark [ __ ]
just perverse [ __ ] and [ __ ] time
wasted
and and i don't deal with that for the
most part when uh when i'm on
taking my soul off do you deal with pain
from all the stunts and all the [ __ ]
you've done and what do you do for pain
not uh i since i got sober 12 years ago
i've not
even filled out a prescription for
painkillers like um
you know it like my rule is that if when
i'm in the hospital
um you know if they got to knock me out
for a procedure then [ __ ] general
anesthesia that's just part of the deal
you know and that's them doing it to me
right right and if while
if while i'm in the hospital they're
gonna put something into my iv
like that's that's fine but my rule is
that once i'm out of the hospital
nothing like i i don't [ __ ] fill out
a prescription because
because that's where it gets slippery
yeah i'm in possession of it and i'm
well taken as prescribed like that's
just a slippery slope though do you
still do stunts do you still do
that [ __ ] are you okay yeah for sure
like you're comfortable with that you're
like you're still
are you are you pretty fearless would
you say god no
i'm gripped by fear i am gripped by fear
i
feel pain and uh and and those are i
think
two very crucial ingredients to um
the success of you know the projects
that
i've been a part of because if i was
fearless there would be no
trepidation they'd be just
to not feel pain but there'd be no
reaction she all right
hey listen uh hey this is called [ __ ]
talking with stevo these are from my
patrons they're just asking you
rapid rapid questions here it is brett g
can you
share a paranormal experience that's
scared the crap out of you
um
very little about uh my paranormal
experiences were scary some of them were
but um yeah i i had uh
like insane hallucinations hearing
voices like
all kinds of uh people walking around
who weren't physically there
while i was on drugs and uh rather than
then regale it i would point you to
stevo ghost stories like uh that's what
he called it i i
told it on the um the h3h3 podcast and i
don't think i could do a better job of
uh
of recounting it so all right
on youtube search stevo ghost stories
christopher m
if time travel was possible would you
want to go into the future or would you
like to visit the past
well anybody would want to go to the
past i think
to uh improve their situation now
right look back to the future too
hey stevo don't jump off that
cliff [ __ ] uh if you can go back
though like
honestly is there anything you would
change that one thing you always
remember like [ __ ]
are there plenty of things that you
would change i would certainly
like to have uh gotten sober
at least
two years sooner right if i if i could
if i could uh
why two years because um i i wouldn't
want
i'd want to be very careful with the
space time continuum
up until that point and uh
and and and the uh i just really
mismanaged opportunities
and uh i got like um the last two years
of my drinking and using
were really [ __ ] uh
destructive humiliating and um
counter counterproductive um so
i mean i i suppose i needed all of that
humiliation and destruction
in order to like be properly motivated
so i probably wouldn't want to mess with
that either
dave p is there a specific stunt that
you performed for jackass that you uh
look back and regret
if for jackass it's all the regrets are
all about
um not digging deeper you know there
were just certain things that i didn't
go
for and so the footage didn't make it
anywhere you know like
um there's nothing i regret doing it's
uh you know we regret what we haven't
done
it's better to regret what you have done
than what you haven't done
and and that's true in my case i like it
maddie asks what stunt did you end up
not doing but wish you would have that's
the there's so many of them
all right the one that comes to mind is
uh
trying to unicycle over a balanced beam
over hot coals in india um i just
couldn't [ __ ] commit to it man and
and it was such a magnificent uh
set and and i just [ __ ] they set it
up for nothing were they pissed
no yeah i mean it's not like that like
um
i was pissed like nobody could possibly
have been more disappointed in me than i
was
and then uh on the subsequent movie we
did the fire gauntlet as a redemption
and it just wasn't nearly as cool were
you ever [ __ ] up on a lot of stunts
um yeah on uh on my own time
for the my two hot for tv dvd series
that was um oh and that all those are
[ __ ] streaming at stevo.com too
um to go to the bottom stevo tv
the uh dude but it was a much
darker operation when uh you know i was
shooting on my own time like then it was
like
you know like if we were too [ __ ] up
filming for jackass then it
it would be a little bit like the end of
boogie nights
where where he's like my card i'm ready
to [ __ ] and he's all tweaked out on meth
and that burt reynolds says like look
man i can't hear him i can't have you on
camera like this you're a [ __ ] mess
you know like
right it's a little bit like jackass is
a little bit more like like that that
makes
art director jeff tremaine a bit like
that burt reynolds you know
it's not it's not the spirit object in
jaguars you see us
like uh you know over the years like
hung over
even acknowledging being hungover there
was not that like
active i'm wasting on camera because
that was never the spirit of it
it was very much the spirit of what i
did on my own time though
right leon p what's your biggest fear um
i mean it's like uh
they i think uh you know
fear i've heard this i've heard fear
defined as uh
you know being
either not getting what you want or
losing what you have
is the basis of uh of of
of all fear i think and um
you know like not getting what you want
i want to be loved i want to be
important you know like
the idea of not getting that you know or
like losing everything
like of course ever you know like i've
worked so hard to save what i have like
i'm afraid of losing it so
i think fear is pretty basic in that
sense alyssa c
final question what is the one thing you
couldn't imagine living without besides
wendy
oh my god if [ __ ] anything happened
to wendy i would
and she comes from the streets so i i
give her like so much freedom i just let
her roam around
i'm gonna do that right now and uh
it's it's just
panic inducing when i'm walking around
looking for it i can't find her but at
the same time i have to give her freedom
maybe something i can't live without
uh i would kind of just say it might see
my team you know
i've got a um
you know my guy scott randolph is like
my my right hand and everything that i
do
with uh you know production and
merchandising and then i've got my other
guy uh
paul paul briskey who's my editor
and um i'd be [ __ ] without both those
guys those guys are my secret weapons
then i have another i have another
secret weapon who's a guy
named guy hickey who lives in australia
and uh i mean this kid guy iggy's just
badass like i met him as
a fan like probably
uh probably
15 years ago maybe i don't know um
and then this kid can just he can just
it's just whatever it is like
seriously if it's finding something
that's really hard to find
like he'll find it you know right
there's
a lot so yeah i i can't live without the
people who um
i work with you know the last thing i
want to say is
i just keep seeing you not getting into
cir
barnum bailey circus school and i just i
i want to know how devastated at that
time in your life you were
i did get into the circus school
specifically it was called uh
ringling brothers and barnum and billy
clown college right and uh
and 33 clowns got it got accepted
all 33 clowns graduated but uh
the idea was only 10 of them 10 of the
clowns got contracts with the
the ringling circus and i was not one of
those 10.
do you think you were worthy you should
have been selected i mean
i i like stuck out like as soon as i
showed up
it was like real with this guy i mean
the reason i went to clown
college was because i wanted to become a
crazy famous stunt man
and um i i just wasn't getting anywhere
on my own you know it was my home video
camera like just nobody cared
and and i just when i found out about
clown college i thought oh
ringling brothers and barnum bailey like
it's this uh
reputable you know
even this it's just like a known name
and then if i was if i could graduate
from
college then i would be a circus
professional people would take me more
seriously as a stuntman so
it was more of just a means to an end
right
like it was evident when i got to clown
college that i had no aspirations of
being a clown
you know my uh i just want i was just
using this as a way to
to further my goal of becoming a stunt
man so
out of the gate that there was that and
then there was like
i was [ __ ] drunk every night you know
like in the first week they had to take
me to the hospital and get my head
stapled together for [ __ ] that i was
doing like
it had nothing to do with [ __ ]
clowning
like uh so yeah i kind of disqualified
myself pretty aggressively right away it
just sounds like a
movie a guy who goes to clown school and
then doesn't get selected as the clown
to go to the circus
it just sounds like a movie um
i mean perhaps you know i wrote a movie
that that uh
my buddy's actually trying to to get
made which is which is crazy
um and it's it's a definitely about a
clown
and how bad does it hurt to get your
when you stapled your balls
would you do you staple uh i mean
there's um
less nerve endings in your ball sack
you know like i would never put a staple
through my actual ball
but through the skin it's not as bad
really like like what i've done
you know repeatedly for years like
stapling my
my ball sack to my leg and i think that
uh
in some cases there's been um the staple
holes in my ball sack
like became infected like there was
there was a couple times where i did
that
and i did another trick where i flip my
balls back and forth and catch them in a
mangina
and doing that like ruptured something
one time like it was filled with
blood my whole ball sack it looked like
a plum
and uh but you know for the most part
it's been pretty minor
your girlfriend or your your uh your
fiance does
did she want to look down there and like
kind of examine do you have scars on
your balls and things
no and if she was going to be examining
it she wouldn't be looking for scars
that's for sure
but yeah my my girl my girl's pretty
[ __ ] down with uh
like all the
[ __ ] she's okay with this because it's
pretty shocking
well dude look man this is this has been
awesome because i don't really i don't
know you i think i might have seen you
somewhere years ago but
i i feel like it's just so easy to talk
to you're so open i just
love that about you and and and stevo
people go on the youtube channel you got
over 5 million followers it's so fun to
just go to video you find yourself there
for like an hour so they just need to go
to stevo.com sibo.com is the hub
where uh where all of my stuff lives
um and uh you know i i gotta i gotta
plug
my book which um please it's uh
special because um on amazon it's got an
average rating of five stars it's it's
you know it's a reliably good book it's
[ __ ] juicier than [ __ ]
and every single copy that i sell at
stevo.com
is personally autographed you know
that's i'm actually down here
at our warehouse in carlsbad designing
books right now
um awesome and uh it's just a [ __ ]
juicy ass book it's meaningful for me to
get it out there because
like uh you know my story
to the extent that it's inspiring and
uplifting and uh
just crazier than [ __ ] um it means a lot
for me to get it out there
what's it called it's a professional
idiot a memoir professional idiot
a memoir get his book i mean your story
is incredible
and it's touching too you can just tell
that there's a lot of heart
and you know you've had a lot of [ __ ]
going on in your life a lot of success
and all that but
we're all striving to be the best we can
and achieve some sort of like
oh being okay with ourselves just being
like all right i'm a [ __ ] up this is who
i am but i'm
doing my best [ __ ] it you know what i
mean
for sure man so man it was a joy talking
to you man anytime you want to come on
man you're you're a pleasure
yeah i appreciate it dude i um yeah i
was looking forward to this
uh it was well worth my time and uh and
thank you to you as well as everybody
else who listens
i also love to do this when i'm on a
podcast that i
think was uh a good experience um
it's it's it's speaking directly to the
people who are still listening because
as podcasters we
you know we've got a drop-off rate you
know and then and those who stick around
to the very end of the podcast who
represent that
[ __ ] full retention rate like they
really are the stars you know
they're they're what we do at all yeah
so speaking to those people who are
still listening this deep into the
podcast
an extra thank you from me and um and if
you really did enjoy it or anything like
shoot me a tweet because when i say hey
you know i listened all the way
if i see tweets i listened all the way
to the end on this podcast [ __ ] thank
you
like those tweets mean like more than
anything so uh
shoot me a tweet if you're still
listening and and uh thanks to everybody
involved
you're a good dude man it was a pleasure
talking to you hey likewise man
thank you i like i like him
there's something just kind of i don't
give a f
about him but i do not me
but like himself like he doesn't like he
almost has it i don't
care but i do care attitude doesn't he
yeah
there's something about that that's kind
of sw sweet it's like
i i'm just gonna do my own thing and i
just don't care about but i do
care how it affects people and i am a
[ __ ] up but
uh you know good for him i enjoyed
talking to him i think he was like who
the [ __ ] is this guy
and then we started talking and but i
was kind of like you know i know him
from jackass and all that stuff but
i really liked him i thought he was a
solid guy
uh thank you to everyone out there
listening thank you uh
check out the the sunspin uh new
uh music video where you can find it on
instagram on
uh sunspin band uh or i'm sure we'll
post on twitter and it's youtube and uh
you can also go to sunspin.com and get
all the merch the sweet cds and t-shirts
and hats and lunch boxes
um tell us what you think you can go to
hello at inside look at this it's right
here
see you can go to hello at
insideyoupodcast.com right
but you could leave messages there i
checked them here and there uh you can
go to the
inside online store and get a bunch of
smallville [ __ ] and uh lunch boxes and
shirts and stuff
uh that's that please write a review if
you love the show uh
to all my patrons out there here's
looking at you
i appreciate all your love and your uh
devotion to the podcast i got these new
shirts for the top tier pot
uh patrons and it's like a one year sort
of like bomb squad b-a-u-m rosen bomb
squad right got it here's a patron shout
out nancy d mary b
leah s tricia f sarah v they're all
right here look at this
little lisa yukiko jill e brian h
lauren g nico p robin s jerry w robert i
jason w stephen j kristin okay
you're on top of it amelia oh
good lord allison l jess j lucas m
raj c joshua d emily
f s [ __ ] cj
p samantha and m good close jennifer and
jackie
stacy l carly h jen s jamal f
janelle b carrie b tab with the 272 not
to be confused with
the two right there ashley ryan kimberly
mike e marissa and el don supremo that's
dan
jackass good old slater ramirez beth b
santiago m
sarah f chad w leanne p rey a maya p
myesha aisha maddie asked kendrick f
ashley f shannon matt w belinda and
kevin v
james r chris h oshborn
amy c we got uh dave h samantha s
spider-man
chase sheila g ray h alyssa c
tab with the t misha n let's go a new
one so if i ask you you know tom
c and tommen henry
s tom and henry asks remember those the
next time
liliana a michelle k what up michelle
hannah b
michael s i could do tracy morgan
talia luke h
john ass i don't i don't really do him
andrew
for a second i did did you see his thing
on the golden globes no was it bad
no he well he uh he announced uh i think
it was best animated
and the winner was seoul but he read the
card as sowell
people dying that's great you know if i
did that
i would get just hounded like this guy
is an idiot you're an idiot but him he
just everybody just thinks it's funny it
was on brand
and it's on brain he didn't mean to do
it
he didn't mean to do it yeah of course
he didn't mean to do it
uh talia m mike s luke h john s
andrew t claire m liz j laura l
chad b rachel e or rochelle i think it's
rochelle
but it's rachel because there's no e at
the end of it so it's rachel i'm right
nathan e brandel d
taylor k neil a marion e
k janelle p dan p jennifer j
wayne m ogetta when i say oh jeddah you
say
oh jeddah lorraine g
uh guys thank you so much for for being
here with us today with
ryan and myself i really appreciate you
and you take the time to listen to the
podcast every week so
spread the word email your friends get
them to listen write a review do all
that [ __ ] thank you for allowing me to
be inside each and every one of you
from ryan and myself here in the
hollywood hills
lifestyles of the rich and famous
lifestyles of the rich
and bombs it's lifestyles of the less
rich and they're not as famous
that's what it is um and there'll be
people who write and go
michael don't do that to yourself you're
famous
you're rich i'm like well rich believe
me i know rich
i know folks that are rich rich is when
you don't have to worry about anything
yeah wealthy is like old money like yes
would you like to drive the rules this
evening ma'am
yeah mom yeah
all right wave at the camera okay uh we
love you
[Music]
i was blaming on the rain oh great